hayek de temps du classement là on est
au top c'est quoi la prochaine chanson
aznavour je t'aime
la prochaine c'est
[Musique]
nous voilà aujourd'hui devant le qg pour
parler d'eux au nord est pour parler du
honor 8x
[Musique]
merci pour le champagne rien de rien
à l'antenne
non
oui
ah mais moi je suis pas très grand tu
sais pas obligé de monter sur l'appareil
oui moi qu'est la nava qu'on sait filmer
ou non séance en rendant ces tous les
deux et c'est normal c'était une icône
est la bienvenue et un peu plus
d'ambiance cuisse il s'arrête mois
attend il ya du champagne au bar exact
dans la récente individus
je vois pas mal ben c'est pas la même
chose que aux nazis
quand je te vois 2
ici le tarif est plutôt intéressante en
a marre
sinon oui oh les beaux buts est
incertain à sers toi on va faire un avis
collective alors ça 8x ça va c'est bien
les gars je trouve pas mal banane c'est
pas cher pas cher se cacher c'est vrai
que c'est pas été parfait c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas tout avoir
on peut pas tout avoir
pourquoi nicolas
je pense qu'un grand téléphone à ce prix
là c'est pas mal whitehall testé on va
voir ce que ça donne et c'est quoi ta
ça c'est vieux rhum du coup à sa hotte
juteux
c'est bon ma foi je prévois l'insertion
métriques accroc la dame et colorée
vasilij c'est le fréquentant chaque
match au prince quentin il a une coupe
et je crois que ces familles voilà
qu'enfin ces 10 août
c'est pourquoi ces cadeaux reste à voir
celle du smartphone
bah franchement il était vraiment sympa
le truc est impressionnant c'est tout ce
qu'ils ont reçu la technologie qu'ils se
réussit à réunir pour le prix qui est de
239 et 1999
excuse-moi 140 morts a investi sur les
prix si monsieur revol précis monsieur
attention le sac à dos et 299 euros et
faurecia 5,88 giga avec un double
capteur un mode portrait
cathy gadrat franchement c'est
impressionnant ça qui est vraiment
impressionnant
et c'est ainsi dans la mer une chaîne et
quand on fait le siège du meilleur vous
pas les meilleurs qui sont beaux jours
et en plus aux frangins excuse moi je
perds mais il n'a pas les petites
bouclettes que tu as fait ça pour moi sa
chance et un atout charme relations se
trouve voilà qu'en ce moment
quant à maintenant ça va plus être
content qu'il veut succès facile avec 10
l'école allez ciao bécassine
d'autant du classement là on est au top
c'est quoi la prochaine chanson
d'aznavour je t'aime
la prochaine c'est
[Musique]
hier a eu lieu la présentation du au
nord 8 x alors je vous le fais en deux
temps ce que hier soir il y avait
beaucoup de bruit dans la soirée c'est
un petit peu compliqué de pouvoir vous
présenter ce produit cette manière a
aujourd'hui on est au csn veulent je
vous en parle d'ici quelques jours
parce qu'on va repartir et las vegas
d'ici quelques mois aujourd'hui il ya le
c est ce qui est présenté bon tout ça on
en reparle dans quelques jours en même
temps et il y en ait deux cadres paris
porte de versailles le salon de l'auto
qui débute demain aujourd'hui je vais
aller visiter un petit peu en vieilles
pies regardez un peu les nouveautés
qu'on va voir du côté de l'automobile ça
aussi on en reparle dans quelques jours
vous invite donc à vous abonner à rester
connectés et là je savais pas qu à porte
de versailles avait des ruches je vous
laisse regarder ne pas dire de bêtises
en cas d'éruption qu'on évitait tout
appliqué voilà ça c'est pour l'anecdote
au nord nous allons présenter un honor
8x super cool voyez il est là on va le
tester d'ici quelques jours
pour l'instant je vais vous le présentez
ce que je vous invite à faire je vais
réaliser le nom boxing et sur ma chaine
hi j tiji
donc je vous ai mis le lien dans la
destruction je vous invite à me
retrouver sur instagram poursuivre le
boxing comme ça sera un peu plus sympa
ce qui est super cool avec ceux au nord
8x surtout c'est son écran on a un écran
de 6,5 pouces
si vous vous intéressez à la tech vous
serez qu'un autre smartphone qui à
l'écran 6,5 pouces en ce moment et qui
est sorti il ya pas très longtemps c'est
l'iphone 10 s max vous avez donc d'un
côté 1 8x coûtera autour de 230 euros
détaillé cela quelques instants et
l'autre côté vous avez un iphone 10 s
max qui coûte plus de 1200 euros alors
ce ne sont pas les mêmes produits on n'a
pas un écran oled super retina on est
sur un écran lcd
néanmoins c'est un smartphone tu es
plutôt bien réussi et surtout la
particularité d'avoir quasiment pas de
manteau en bas et ça pour le coup c'est
vraiment bien c'est une première dans
cette gamme de prix
bravo au nord et je vous dis un petit
menton supplémentaires mais vraiment
très très fort sur l'iphone 8 x par
rapport à l'iphone 10 s max à noter que
vous avez également une tout petite
encoche ici c'est plutôt pas mal le
design est assez bien réussi on retrouve
vraiment le design cas huawei qu'à
sortir well et cp 20 pro b 20 et puis
vint light cette année c'est à dire une
écriture de la marque capteur photo vous
avez si l'écriture haï caméra capteur
d'empreinte digitale au centre sur la
tranche le bouton pour l'allumer haut
parleur mono micro usb prise jack point
de vue design il est très bien réussi et
je vous dis sur la face avant
rêverez vraie amélioration petite
encoche pas de menton très bien vous
avez donc un écran qui occupent 91% de
la face avant c'est un écran full view
avec un ratio 19,5 9e avec une
définition eiffage des plus de 2340 par
1080 pixels à 3 197 p pays et ce que
nous dit au nord c qui tient dans la
main comme un smartphone de 5,8 pouces
en gros il a le format d'un iphone 10 s
max mais il tient dans la main comme
l'iphone dissous comme l'iphone 10 s
c'est un petit peu l'idée côté
performances on retrouve à l'intérieur
un kirin 710 octas core gravé en 12 km
avec le gpu turbo le gpu sur bon on en a
déjà parlé c'est une amélioration
logiciel qui vous permet vraiment
d'optimiser complètement votre machine
en termes de ressources gain d'autonomie
et en termes de puissance et ça marche
extrêmement bien au nord nous annonce un
gain de puissance de 75 % par rapport au
nord c'est x sagan évidemment à vérifier
lors des phases de test il a 4 gigas de
ram et soit 64 giga de stockage soit 128
giga de stockage extensible jusqu'à 400
giga grâce à une carte microsd à noter
que vous avez aussi un doux le tiroir de
cartes sim donc deux cartes sim une
carte microsd c'est plutôt pas mal et
niveau autonomie au nord nous annonce
sonne une autonomie jusqu'à un jour et
demi en utilisation intensive
grâce à une batterie de 3750
milliampères earth a bien évidemment on
veut aussi vérifier lors des phases de
tests d'ici quelques jours
donc je vous invite à faire une chose
c'est à vous abonner et à rester
connectés entre techno qui était
présenté sur le honor plaît il n'y a pas
très longtemps c'est le cap des smart
shops c'est-à-dire un smartphone qui va
vibrer lors de partygaming pour vraiment
avoir une sensation beaucoup plus
d'immersion
lorsque vous allez mettre un coup d'épée
vous allez en prendre un ou deux ça
bouge ça tourne ce matin deux là se met
à vibrer plus sympa et beaucoup plus de
sensation lors de parties de jeux côté
photo vous avez un double capteur 20
mégapixels + 2 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.8 et à l'avant vous
avez une caméra de 16 mégapixels ou non
nous annonce des clichés nocturne
complètement optimisé grâce à une prise
de photos de six secondes encaissé
nocturne vous permet d'avoir des images
beaucoup plus lumineuse une stabilité
quelque chose qui va pas du tout bougé
une image de qualité c'est bien
évidemment vos cils vérifier d'ici
quelques temps à noter qu il tourne sous
android
8.1
et la surcouche maison c'est em 8 points
2 vous pouvez faire du snow motion à 480
images par seconde
et comme c'est noté là c'est un
smartphone qui boostait à l'intelligence
artificielle il reconnaît donc 22
catégories d'image différentes pour 500
scénario ce qui lui permettra d'avoir
des photos complètement optimisé
quelles que soient les circonstances que
vous photographier leurs repas natures
mortes des plantes votre grand-mère qui
vous voulez la photo sera complètement
optimisé
à noter qu'à l'intérieur vous avez du
bluetooth 4 points 2 à noter que vous
avez aussi une techno qui s'appelle pib
qui est là pour réduire les lumières
bleues vous savez que il ya des études
qui montrent que trop d'exposition aux
écrans à cause des lumières bleues
augmenter le risque de dm et là c'est
une dégénérescence maculaire leur éviter
de passer un petit peu ce côté là un peu
trop médical mais l'idée effectivement
c'est que les constructeurs font
vraiment focus pour protéger vos yeux et
ça c'est plutôt bien vous avez un mode
fête qui permet de connecter
cette smart phones ensemble pour avoir
de la musique lors d'une soirée bon je
sais vous avez que vous étiez enceinte
bluetooth pour mettre de la musique mais
bon pourquoi pas ça peut être un intérêt
ça peut être sympa ça smartphones qui
est dispo en bleu au noir et en rouge
à noter que dans la boîte vous avez une
petite coque de protection qui offerte
coque transparente qui vous coûtera en
version 4 gigas de ram et 64 go de
stockage 249 euros et 4 gigas de ram 128
jk de stockage 299 euros autant vous
dire qu'à ce prix là pour ne pas avoir
de menton pour avoir une petite encoche
un écran 6,5 pouces qualité au nord avec
le gpu turbo franchement intéressant il
est dispo dès maintenant dans toutes les
bonnes crémeries je vous ai mis des
liens en bas dans la description
s'il vous intéresse bon et comme je vous
le dis d'ici quelques jours on va les
tester en conditions réelles on va
regarder s kiddies activement du côté de
la photo de la vidéo de l'autonomie de
la performance en faire un test
souvent tout ou en faire tourner des
jeux on va regarder ce qu'il est
intéressant donc je vous invite pour
savoir tout ça bien évidemment à vous
abonner et à rester connectés dans
l'événement ou nord a présenté deux
montres connectés là haut normande 4 et
là haut normande 4 running du coûtent
respectivement 49 et 39 euros
[Musique]